If I were a young woman now, I'm not sure how I'd cope.
With all the things that you have, the opportunities, the technology,...
...I'd like to think it could be a world of pleasure,...
...but I fear instead it would only be a world of pressure.
Pressure to be the perfect mother, the perfect wife, the perfect friend,...
...pressure to be successful, a boss, a leader.
If I had my time again, I wouldn't create a to-do list; I'd create it to don't-do list.
I'd give myself the time to indulge in the things...
...that I now understand are the most important.
What I wouldn't give to extend those good night kisses...
...instead of moaning about having to get up early in the morning.
Oh, what I wouldn't give for an extra second of cuddling my babies...
...before they became too big to hold.
What I wouldn't give for five more minutes on the dance floor...
...while my legs were still strong enough to carry me.
This is simply about you as a human being.
There is the most important word: being...
...being lost in the moment,...
...being at peace with the world,...
...being kinder to myself,...
...being kinder to others,...
...being able to let go and being proud to do so.
Believe me, if I were a young woman now, I'd spend more time being,...
...not doing.